hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
enigmatic gate of death that is the veil
now if one were to venture through the
corridors of the ministry of magic for
long enough they'd likely eventually
find themselves standing before the
enigmatic Veil a haunting manifestation
nestled within the death chamber of the
Department of mysteries and when faced
with such an enigmatic Wizarding
structure it's hard not to ask questions
what is the veil who created it and how
does the veil connect to the Wizarding
world's understanding of Life Death and
the Beyond join me as we operate through
time and space diving deep into the
mysteries of the veil and shedding light
on its presence within Wizarding history
what is it you may remember the heart
stopping moment when in Harry Potter and
the Order of the Phoenix we stepped into
the department of mysteries a tangled
Labyrinth of Enchantment and hush-hush
operations
within the heart of the ministry of
magic and who could forget the
unspeakables highly dedicated and
secretive witches and wizards that
dedicated their lives to working in the
department but perhaps the most chilling
Revelation to come from our introduction
to this department is the veil this
ancient Relic time worn and filled with
whispered Secrets resides in an ebb and
drenched chamber known as the death
chamber this Stone Deus draped with a
crumbling ripped and strangely
memorizing black veil was like nothing
we'd seen before in our journey through
the Wizarding World the massive ancient
stone Archway which stands in the center
of the death chamber acts as a sort of
portal between the lands of the living
and the dead it is believed that those
who step through the veil or fall
through become trapped in the world of
death those who stand close enough and
have belief in the afterlife are also
able to hear faint whisperings that
appeared to come from the other side
some characters in the series like Harry
and Luna found themselves able to hear
the beckoning from the other side of
this draped Enigma on the other hand
characters last touched by death or
perhaps shielded from it like Hermione
and Ginny heard nothing but silence for
these reasons many believe the veil to
be a glimmering threshold guarding
departed Souls into the next realm a
Gateway between the Realms of living and
the dead that was created by ancient
witchcraft at least that's one Theory
another theory posits that the veil was
created by the development of mysteries
as a means to study death and the other
side more closely after all the ministry
is no stranger to tampering with forces
beyond their comprehension as we've seen
with the time Turners and dangerous
prophecies
fortunately JK Rowling herself as
weighed in on the Enigma of the veil
confirming its prevalence as the Divide
between life and death during a July
2007 interview with Bloomsbury while she
didn't go into detail about the veil's
origins it's clear that the veil holds
great significance in the World of Harry
Potter embodying a powerful connection
between the Realms of the living and the
deceased expanding on this further
there's actually a phrase in the English
language Beyond the Veil that refers to
the mysterious state Beyond Death the
phrase in turn originates from a Hebrew
phrase describing the location of the
Tabernacle in a Jewish temple history
the ministry of magic is the primary
form of government in the magical world
at least in the UK and was founded in
1707 along with the appointment of the
very first Minister for magic you like
gamp like a Mughal government the
ministry's responsibilities are vast as
they are the primary body that attempts
to sustain Law and Order in the magical
world and like any system of government
in an effort to cover as much ground as
possible the primary governmental body
is systematically divided to focus on
different sectors of The Wizarding World
these sectors or departments cover the
more common areas like the department of
magical law enforcement and the
department of magical Transportation but
there are also other departments
reserved for Less obvious Pursuits this
brings us to level 9 and the enigmatic
Department of mysteries the department
of mysteries is responsible for studying
the mysteries of the Wizarding World
Mysteries associated with love space
thought time death and other things
basically anything thing that is unknown
the divisions of this department are
broken up by area of study and includes
the following the brain room the Hall of
Prophecy the death chamber the love
chamber the space chamber and the time
room these rooms are accessed via the
room of doors a large circular room
where everything is black but well above
anything else the most mysterious thing
about the department of mysteries is
that it actually preceded the existence
of the ministry itself the ministry was
established in 1707 and the department
of mysteries had activity as early as
1672. at least activity that's
documented given that the veil is
located inside of the Department of
mysteries I'd be willing to bet that the
ancient Archway also far preceded the
existence of the ministry in fact given
that the structure predates the ministry
of magic I'd like to put forth the idea
that the ministry of magic and
Department of mysteries were actually
constructed around it marking the
chamber off as a place of significance
to expand on this further let me next
take a look at who created it now let me
first just say that the answer of who
created the veil has never been
explicitly mentioned anywhere however
there is one theory that stands out to
Me Above the Rest and that's that death
himself created the enigmatic Archway
the figure of death plays a significant
role in the Harry Potter series
specifically in Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows drawing from the tale of
the Three Brothers which is a story
featured in the tales of beetle The Bard
death interacts with the three-fabled
pevel brothers and bestows upon them
three magical objects these objects
known as the Deathly Hallows Encompass
the Elder Wand the resurrection Stone
and the invisibility cloak each object
in the story can be correlated to the
desire to control or cheat death the
Elder Wand which is represented by the
vertical line in the symbol is believed
to be the most powerful one in existence
it signifies the desire for power and
its wielders often meet in an untimely
end due to the constant pursuit of power
of a death the resurrection Stone
symbolized by the circle has the ability
to bring back the dead albeit as mere
Shadows of their former selves the stone
emphasizes the desire to reconnect the
deceased and the potential dangers of
meddling with the natural order of life
and death and lastly the invisibility
cloak depicted as the triangle grants
its wearer the power to be invisible in
the tale it symbolizes the acceptance of
one's inevitable mortality as the third
brother ultimately uses it to evade
death until he is ready to embrace it
although The Tale of Three Brothers is a
fictitious story within the series it
serves as an allegory for the human
desire to overcome control or escape
death as such the figure of death and
its portrayal in the tale represents the
natural force that all living beings
must face it also stresses the Timeless
message of accepting one's mortality and
The Perils of attempting to subvert the
natural course of life and though death
is a fictitious character if even within
the magical world I can't help but
wonder if there's some truth to the tale
of the Three Brothers particularly as
all three Hallows have proven to be very
much real the veil much like the Deathly
Hallows in the tale seems to possess
incomprehensible qualities related to
life death and the afterlife its
enigmatic nature and connection to death
might imply that an entity is potent as
death itself could be behind its
existence a veil is even mentioned in
the tale of the Three Brothers when
describing the second Brothers
resurrected fiancee yet she was silent
and cold separated from him as though by
a veil but I'm certainly not ignorant to
the fact that the existence of some
tangible form of death opens up a whole
other can of worms death gave all three
brothers one of the fabled Duffy Hallows
and they all had their own unique fate
but it also seems like regardless of the
decisions that the brothers made or the
actions that they took they ultimately
all faced death once again and the way
that it's depicted in the story shows
them physically encountering this same
personification of death that they faced
in the beginning if the tale is real and
Beetle The Bard was simply retelling an
aspect of History how did he know about
what had happened what did he really
know of the relationship between death
and the brothers was it fact or fiction
one thing to consider is that the tales
of beetle The Bard continually reinforce
these stories are in fact the author's
original Creations however that
certainly doesn't mean that beedle did
not draw inspiration from his real life
experiences the things that he had done
or the people that he had met JK Rowling
supplies the following forward to the
book if his stories accurately reflect
his opinions he rather liked Muggles
whom he regarded as ignorant rather than
malevolent he mistrusted dark magic and
he believed that the worst excesses of
wizard kind sprang from the all too
human traits of Cruelty apathy or
arrogant misapplication of their own
talents the heroes and heroines who
Triumph in his stories are not those
with the most powerful magic but rather
those who demonstrate the most kindness
common sense and Ingenuity there's
little evidence to support either
argument and that these stories were
fabricated entirely all that Beetle Drew
inspiration from something that he had
witnessed in his life however given that
the Hallows actually exist I'm willing
to bet that it was a latter we know the
three Hallows genuinely exist and that
can be confirmed but was the
personification of a deathly figure just
Beetle adding his own spin to the story
or was death a real wizard this is where
it gets tricky as it stands there is no
proof that suggests that death
personified is indeed real his existence
is only mentioned one work and it's a
fictional one to say that death exists
because of this one book for children is
a stretch particularly as the existence
of the Hallows is the only real argument
one could make for his existence and
there could be many ways that the
howlers themselves were created Albus
Dumbledore didn't seem to have much
faith in the validity of death's
existence so it's true asked Harry all
of it the pepper brothers were the three
brothers of the tale said Dumbledore
nodding oh yes I think so whether they
met death on a lonely road I think it
more likely that the purple brothers
were simply gifted dangerous Wizards who
succeeded in creating those powerful
objects the story of them being death's
own Hallows seems to me the sort of
legend that might have sprung up around
such Creations it's hard to answer the
question as to whether or not death
truly existed there are many powerful
artifacts in the Harry Potter universe
and the Hallows though powerful don't
seem outside the realm of possibility
for other powerful witches and wizards
with that said if death truly was
responsible for creating the three
Hallows I'd be willing to bet that he
was also responsible for the creation of
the veil one other closing thought is
that the veil and the resurrection Stone
from the tale of the Three Brothers have
undeniable similarities both objects
serve as gateways or barriers between
those who are living and dead the only
difference is the achievable level of
communication with the stone you can
generate actual physical Shades that you
can directly interact with whereas with
the veil it has been expressed that you
can only hear if you listen closely
those from the Land of the Dead we know
that when Cadmus the brother who picks
the stone and death have their
interaction the stone that death gives
Cadmus was simply picked up from the
riverbank where the death Enchanted that
stone right then and there is up for you
to decide but given that the veil is
constantly described as crumbling
cracked and so ancient that it's barely
able to stand I think that the
resurrection stone is perhaps just a
piece that broke off it may seem like a
bit of a stretch but I think there's got
to some kind of connection what do you
guys think do you have any theories as
to who created the enigmatic veil in the
ministry's death chamber was death real
on the resurrection Stone and Veil
linked in some way please let me know
down in the comment section below if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel also be
sure to check out more content over on
Harry Potter Theory extra where I post
an additional three videos a week until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live